[Musique]
embarquement immédiat pour rio de
janeiro là où le brésil s'invente un
nouvel avenir à la veille de plusieurs
événements planétaires
le thermomètre du pays continent est en
surchauffe
pour découvrir ce qui fait vibrer les
cariocas les habitants de rio qu'il soit
artiste expatriés figurent des favelas
où amoureux de la mer il faut plonger en
profondeur dans cette capitale du
métissage en pleine renaissance
les minimes ailleurs la reine des
bikinis invente des modèles haute
couture qui font fureur sur les plages
[Musique]
une nature envoûtante un décor de rêve
il faut prendre de la hauteur pour
explorer l'envers de la carte postale
entre mer et montagne les favelas des
quartiers qui ont longtemps fait peur
depuis peu des gringos les investisse
axel un jeune français a décidé de
devenir favelas dos pour y construire sa
pousada une maison d'hôtes à la
brésilienne
[Musique]
dans les quartiers nord de rio un
immense lagon artificiel bien loin de la
jet set d'ipanema
[Musique]
celui que l'on surnomme fait jean le
patron de la piscine des favelas est une
figure locale qui veut transformer
l'image de ces quartiers déshérités
[Musique]
au sud de rio un chapelet d'îles sauvage
katia une jeune plongeuse a décidé de
tout faire pour préserver la vie des
dauphins les sentinelles de ce petit
paradis
aujourd'hui menacée par la folle
ascension du brésil
[Musique]
d'un extrême à l'autre
voyage au brésil à rio de janeiro dans
l'une des villes les plus extravagants
du moment
ipanema 9 heures du matin
sur son vélo électrique l'énigme
ailleurs vient chaque matin chercher
l'inspiration
tout a commencé pour elle sur cette
plage tout droit venu de sao paulo elle
a débarqué ici pour la première fois
dans les années 70 comment tu vas je
veux bien et toi à quel délice la
première fois que je suis arrivé ici
j'ai eu le souffle coupé
à rio de janeiro à l'époque les bikinis
était tout petit et on les met pour cela
mais on voulait être un peu plus
couverts pour être plus confortable mais
ça n'existait pas
mes copines à sao paulo me demandait de
ramener des maillots plus large et du
coup je me suis dit que j'allais en
créer un
j'ai pris un ancien paréo à moi je les
coupe et c'était une chose très
artisanal la chance c'est qu'un jeu ça
avec coudre ça a été un succès et tout
le monde a commencé à me passer des
commandes
j'étais moi-même le même qu'un jeu les
ramenait à la plage pour en offrir à des
copines et c'est à ce moment que tout a
commencé
amélie monde voulait en acheter et porté
le bikini de l'ennemi j'ai alors créé
une petite fabrique au fond d'un garage
dans le quartier de l'agoa c'était une
autre époque
[Musique]
du simple de pièces à la version string
le plus grand défilé au monde de bikini
a lieu sur les plages de rio de janeiro
c'est le costume de la girl from ipanema
[Musique]
des filles qui défilent toute la journée
sur la plage
un cocktail détonant mélange de soleil
d'eau et de culte du corps métissé qui a
révolutionné l'image du brésil
[Musique]
le bikini un petit bout de tissu qui
n'est pourtant pas né au brésil
tout a commencé à la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale
[Musique]
le 1er juillet 46 a eu lieu sur l'atoll
de bikini dans l'océan pacifique une
explosion atomique
le but de l'opération validée la
puissance destructrice de la bombe à
attention mettez vos masques
où des explosions les plus
impressionnantes de l'histoire
provoquant des tsunamis de plus de 30
mètres de haut
[Musique]
cinq jours plus tard louis réard un
ingénieur mécanicien français invente le
deux pièces qu'il surnomme bikini en
référence à l'explosion atomique qui
vient d'avoir lieu
du jamais vu le sulfureux maillot de
bain fut interdite sur de nombreuses
plages on le déclare dangereux pour la
santé
c'est à partir des années 60 qu'il se
démocratise brigitte bardot s'affiche
légèrement vêtues et hollywood
l'adoptent dans la foulée
[Musique]
louis réard a réussi son coup le bikini
est devenue culte
il a conquis les femmes du monde entier
[Musique]
retour à rio dans la capitale du bikini
pour rencontrer la reine des maillots de
bain il faut se rendre dans le quartier
très chic de la gombe un lac au milieu
de la ville et en face des hôtels
particuliers
c'est ici que vit léninisme ailleurs ça
c'est le roi de la maison
tiens ça c'est pour toi mon petit chien
c'est bon le brésil est de loin le
numéro un mondial sur le marché du
bikini 300 millions de pièces vendues
chaque année un enjeu national est une
formidable opportunité pour les nids
elle a fait fortune en créant des
collections de luxe bien plus qu'un
simple maillot de bain il est ici à rio
une seconde peau l'esprit carioca c'est
la plage peu importe que tu es de
l'argent ou pas tout le monde est
content de se mélanger
t
démocrate on dit toujours que la plage
est très démocratique ici mais en fait
il y à des tribus d'un coup d'oeil on
veut savoir d'où tu viens
cela dépend de la manière dont tu portes
le bikini qu en fonction de la taille la
couleur les chapeaux et des accessoires
que tu utilises cela permet d'identifier
les femmes plus que n'importe quel homme
et cela est très amusant si les gens me
disaient pas ici nous arrivons
maintenant dans une entreprise dans le
quartier de botafogo
merci à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
en femme d'affaires avisée lenny a
rendez vous avec ses fournisseurs pour
choisir les tissus de la prochaine
saison
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour saluer
n'y a pas mal pas mal fort calais du
café non je vous remercie
regarde les nids j'ai trouvé ce tissu
avec des petits trous plus petits
regarde il est pas mal celui-ci j'adore
ma glace je le trouve gracieux j'aime ça
que c'est quoi la baisse du prix de
celui-ci on a je vois ça tout de suite
les nids tu me fais un super prix pour
moi il y aussi en faux cuir matière prix
photo line y supervise le moindre détail
maintenant je suis en train de finir
d'éditer un catalogue avec des photos de
michael roberts
mais je suis à la femme ma collection
d'hiver et je suis en train de préparer
ma collection pour l'été prochain
son défi être à l'avant-garde pour
surprendre chaque été avec de nouvelles
créations à l'étagé du dessous les
petites mains du bikini donne vie aux
croquis de l'aîné
[Musique]
il y à plus d'une centaine de fabricants
à rio pour un marché qui dépasse le
milliard d'euros
comme dans une maison de haute couture
lenny gère tout à domicile
[Musique]
ici travaillent 150 personnes dans la
production et
c'est très important de travailler dans
les mêmes endroits
car comme ça je peux accompagner de près
dans toutes les étapes de la fabrication
ont fait environ 1000 bikini par jour en
temps normal d'activité qu'ils vont en
voyage
et d'ici les bikinis partent en voyage
très pour habiller les brésiliennes de
française les américaines les anglaises
etc
si dieu le veut il y a les bikinis pour
le marché mondial est dans une petite
salle à part un laboratoire dans lequel
s'invente le bikini du futur viens par
ici ici c'est la salle d'assemblage
c'est là que tout n'est ici luzia
travaillent avec moi depuis 15 ans j'ai
un modèle de chaque bikini qu'on a créés
et allez ça qu'ils ont mais qui mixtent
m
il y en a des fous ça c'est le bikini
qui est totalement tissé à la main par
exemple ce maillot a été créé pour le
défilé de la collection d'été de l'année
dernière ont fait avec de la peau d'un
vrai qu'au bras évidemment on fait
l'édition exclusive et limitée
la complexité pour le fabriquer c'est de
réussir à utiliser de la peau de serpent
sur un maillot ça a été un vrai succès
car c'est très original
on a déjà vu l'utilisation du serpent
pour fabriquer des chaussures des sacs à
main et faire un maillot de bain en peau
de serpent
c'était la première fois c'était une
vraie réussite dans les filets de mode
et les un autre modèle qui a été un défi
pour nous c'est un bandage unique une
seule pièce dans le genre claudia tard
en bo2 cobra aux façons de la dia teurs
rien de tel pour prendre un dernier bain
de soleil sur la plage d'ipanema
[Musique]
18 heures le rendez vous des vrais
carioca
après le boulot ils prennent le temps de
vivre en famille ou profitent d'une
dernière vague
oui
[Musique]
au petit matin axel un jeune français
conquis par riot guide les touristes
loin des sentiers battus
[Musique]
la plage d'ipanema tu la vois
correctement que ce qui je pense est bon
la paix guanabara céline avec du monde
naturel
[Musique]
à leurs pieds les joyaux de riom mais
aussi ses immenses bidonvilles à flanc
de colline la balade refinir qui ne
présentent pas l'ati points
c'est le début des signes accroché à la
montagne des deux frères la favela de
vie djigueul un dédale de constructions
anarchiques qui surplombe l'océan
[Musique]
où
axel s'est spécialisé dans ce tourisme
d'un nouveau genre donc tu vois la
favela
c'est tout le temps en en construction
s'est jamais visité mais qu'il s'arrête
jamais la visite de ces quartiers
défavorisés
[Musique]
prendre des photos n'est ce pas
il y a deux ans axel était étudiant en
école de commerce il a tout plaqué pour
riom depuis il voit ses quartiers d'un
autre oeil
plus simplement un point où la vie est
misérable mais aussi une opportunité
pour se faire une place au soleil des
prix accessibles et des points de vue
spectaculaires
il a investi toutes ses économies dans
cette maison avec vue sur le pain de
sucre
il a ouvert ici une maison d'hôtes dans
la favela et les clients viennent du
monde entier
aujourd'hui ce sont des colombiens une
grille d alvaro qui sont intéressés par
ce nouveau concept
salut ingrid tu vas bien ici c'est le
premier étage et les chambres sont en
bas je vais vous montrer
il y en a plusieurs et on discutera de
celles que vous souhaitez louis lagarde
allez on y va
moi je condamne et je vais le cacher
c'est vraiment trop de bazas bien sûr on
doit encore faire des améliorations
[Musique]
voilà il ya un autre salon bateau reste
en coupe à toutes les chambres sont
occupées et celle là elle se libère
normalement fin juillet il faut que je
vérifie avec le locataire
nous on viendrait à partir du mois
d'août parce que c'est possible
à qui la verdad acquis à la cause digne
qui ici en vérité c'était une cuisine
inesta et regardez il ya toujours les
vielles on a caché en dessous paquet à
pire c'est le lavabo ici avant c'est une
cuisine et on a pas on a fait ça est
alors eu commission a réussi donc
ingrid a parce que alvaro il travaille
dans un bar à santa teresa et puis il a
discuté avec un de mes amis comme quoi
il cherchait une chambrée cet ami en
question m'a mis en relation avec eux ce
qu'ils sont de colombie et il voyage
pendant onze des zazous un an et donc il
voulait poser leurs bagages un petit peu
à rio pour profiter et découvrir la
ville en plus plus en profondeur
cette vue est unique c'est travailler
dans le quartier tranquille
le visuel de santa teresa normalement
c'est plus vers la zone nord là ici
c'est superbe
il ya des personnes qui louent des
chambres improvisé dans la favela qui
fait qu'il ya de plus en plus de
touristes qui choisissent cette formule
pauliste ici c'est bien
des travaux d amélioration l'espace est
agréable dans les autres maisons que
l'on a visité il ya des murs improvisé
parfois avec une planche en bois
c'est très mal faire et en plus c'est
cher cette chambre ici elle coûte 250
euros tout compris avec 250 euros par
mois donc avec avec tout cas internet et
si tu veux des gens comme ça dans un
hôtel mais tu peux encore améliorer pas
dans un automne mais ne serait-ce que en
bas dans un une colocation lambda dans
un immeuble normale à rio aujourd'hui ça
montre tout de suite à 400 euros tout de
suite et tu ne pas pas bien sur cette
vue avec ce que moi je considère cette
qualité de vie si on veut très
tranquille c'est vraiment très posé non
il sera en bas d'un immeuble n'aura pas
de juger recherche aux trois pas d'air
sept chambres pour accueillir des
voyageurs latinos ou des saxophonistes
irlandais salue l'état carlos tu vas
jouer en rond et tu joues au club du
maze a la garde
une auberge espagnole emilio un
brésilien de la classe moyenne vient de
s'installer dans la favela un choix
inimaginable il ya encore quelques
années
c'est curieux parce que si je fais
pareil a même eu deux trois ans marc
vazy que d'aller habiter dans une favela
avec des étrangers et ça se passerait
trop bien il n'y a pas de souci mais
voilà je suis là où tout se passe bien
c'est une situation improbable ouais
même encore remet pas
julien tu vas les sons et ils viennent
ici j'adore et trouve sa femme s'est
aussi déjà une surprise de trouver un
endroit comme ça ça fait ça fait pas
partie de nos vies tu as finalement
avant de venir vivre ici je n'avais pas
l'habitude d'aller dans les favelas où
dans des endroits pareils et c'est
encore étonnant ma famille qui vient
mais pat qui viennent c'est trop bien ça
se passe bien mais c'est quand même un
petit choc pendant longtemps les favelas
de rio étaient des quartiers hors la loi
trafiquants de drogue et police ce livre
est ici une guerre sans merci
jusqu'au jour où le gouvernement décide
d'employer les grands moyens
plus de 3000 militaires investissent les
quartiers les plus chauds de la ville
lors d'opérations dit de pacification
[Musique]
or
l'état reprend la main les favelas
redeviennent fréquentable une révolution
pour ces quartiers qui vivaient sous
l'emprise des gangs les habitants
respirent
axel et ses locataires peuvent
aujourd'hui vivre en paix
[Musique]
valentin naud que l'on va chercher des
lits donc c'est vicens qui m'a préparé
des lits en une structure métallique
bon ça c'est sympa il a fait tout un
système je trouve à pouvoir la chambre
fois dans la chambre la chambre
accordions ou temporaires que j'appelle
il va pouvoir les rabattre complètement
contre un mur et heureusement que tu es
là parce que c'est un petit peu lourd
quand c'est du beau faire c'est un
personnage il a il a une maison a cédé à
particulière il habite en bas partons de
la favela
donc on va devoir tout monté tout en bas
de la favela ils vont voir le champion
local du système d le dénommé vicens
spécialiste en soudure et ferronnerie il
fini de transformer des portes
grillagées en lits 17
usage tu vas bien c'est pas un drame non
ça me prendra encore un peu de temps
combien de temps faut une quinzaine de
minutes
c'est bientôt fini quinze minutes on
peut pas le finir là ou si c'est bon
la présentatio valence et présente
valente et il va nous aider pour monter
le matériel car à deux ça va être dur il
tendra les pièces les moins lourde mais
n'en reste à bord 10 est plutôt sur le
côté bas de la favela
il vit ici depuis comme quoi tout ça
trente deux ans et ça fait 32 ans que
vis à vis ici
il a connu les favelas comment tout
était fort et juste la forest tous les
petits travaux en terre dans la favela
c'est qu'il ait fait les portes en fer
les fenêtres les barbecues du budget
l'écart de femme et sa fille
on va d'aider quelqu'un a besoin de
quelque chose en fer services et ce qui
va pas par ici dans son atelier ici
c'est une petite femme est la toute fin
des services financiers opaques
[Musique]
dans un article
l'avis du fawe elle à dos est une vie de
montagnards il faut sans cesse escalader
des milliers de marche pas simple
la peinture n'est pas sage
ça ne tachent les vêtements combien ça
pèse coquilles ça doit peser 20 kg beach
qui c'est léger mondiale on dirait que
ça pèse 40 kg et un gringalet
[Musique]
trente minutes d'ascension sont
nécessaires pour arriver chez axel
[Musique]
profitez de la vue incroyable du haut de
la favela cela se mérite
ça commence à être un peu dur là on
n'est qu'à la moitié mais bon tous les
jours enfin il arrive dans pas longtemps
à balai ou le téléphone plus de lits ont
choisi un savoir faire qui arrive à son
ca va se presser un petit peu donc
rafale c'est mon grand ami et est grand
partenaire de mon aventure avec la
maison avec qui donc j'ai acheté la
maison il ya un an et demi et l'a donc
rafale il devait finir ses études
d'architecturé en france nous fier et
très content de revenir et j'ai moi
aussi quoi de le recevoir sur tout
à gaza t'es fatigué ça va on arrive dans
cinq minutes
c'est comme une autre
comment
la favela c'est comme un petit village
salut je fais une fête à la maison
ok sa page venir avec ma famille vous
pouvez venir vers 8 heures allez on se
doit ce soir super voilà c'est mes
voisins proches et donc ce soir on a
organisé une petite une petite fête pour
l'arrivée de raphaël justement et j'en
profite pour inviter un de tous les
voisins
ça fait beaucoup comme ça ici à savoir
faire vite au dernier moment les gens
qui croisent quoi mais bon ça va vite à
les infos donc ils le savent tous déjà
c'est à quelle heure à partir de 7
heures j'ai aussi invité ta mère
ok très bien on fait une photo a
d'ailleurs plein de monde ça va être
super
à brazil aragonite des brésiliennes sont
mignonnes ici dans la favela on n'a pas
à se plaindre
oui il ya pas mal de jolies filles ici
mais c'est un petit quartier quand même
ouais mais dans tout rio voilà c'est
autre chose
il y en a pour tous les goûts chez accel
ambiance communautaire heitor le
saxophoniste prépare le repas du soir
vincenz le roi de la débrouille installe
une chambre d'appoint sorti tout droit
de son imagination
si une chambre temporaire que je puisse
déplier quand j'ai besoin de lits pour
recevoir des amis des invités de manière
temporaire quelques nuits et donc la vie
saine si on a travaillé avec des sages
sur un système de grands panneaux en
bois qui se déplie vous allez voir ça
elle assure la porte
et voilà le travail une nouvelle chambre
à moindre frais
[Musique]
toute la petite maison s'affairent pour
fêter l'arrivée de l'associé d'axel une
cinquantaine de personnes sont attendues
[Musique]
je m'appelle ramos et je viens déposer
rappel c'est koné avec les photos ne pas
tendre 107 shu
[Musique]
cela fait plus d'un an qu'il n'est pas
venu raphaël découvre les changements ça
si tu veux te sentir vraiment
l'extérieur tu te sens extérieur quoi
j'aspire à faya pierre de taper en face
de la glace pour pouvoir avoir de bière
fraîche
[Musique]
ce soir des expatriés et des locaux sont
au rendez-vous lui
et parmi eux l'ancien propriétaire des
lieux
tu vois là on a fait un bar et là bas il
ya une baie vitrée
[Musique]
cécilia qui est le propriétaire de la
maison et qui vient avec sa petite fille
à une avis ensuite j'ai six jeunes rats
mais un peu plus tard dans la farine et
leur ricardo c'est le mari de
marionnettes qui est la soeur de 10,6
favela où tous se connaissent et tu
famille
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'acsel
m c'est comme un frère mon rythme
je suis contente de revoir mon ancienne
maison il a bien profité de l'espace et
vous habitez ou maintenant j'habite le
quartier de bal à mt fait mieux là bas
c'est différent vous reprenez c'est une
maison mais je n'ai plus une si belle
baie comme celle d'ici vous avez quitté
la favela
non là bas aussi c'est une favela mais
les plus près de la route et que
pensez-vous de la transformation de
votre ancienne maison à c'est super beau
je ne m'attendais pas du tout à ça tu
comprends il a fait du bon boulot
j'espère que ça va faire un marché des
favelas qui change de mains axel et son
camarade sont des pionniers peu de
gringos vivent encore dans ces quartiers
mais plus pour longtemps
des spots avec une vue incroyable une
idée qui commence à faire son chemin
vivre dans la favela n'est plus réservé
aux pauvres
face à l'explosion du prix de
l'immobilier à rio axel et raphaël ont
réussi un joli coup
ils vivent dans plus de 200 m² avec une
vue de millionnaire ils ont fait de gros
travaux de rénovation et c'est loin
d'être fini
le planning est chargé pas de plage au
programme mais maçonnerie et ravalement
ouais donc je disais qu'ils prennent
aussi des gens là vous pourrez devenir
apple qu'est ce que tu veux faire de
concret quoi avant ton départ je veux
qu'on peut être qu'on aménage des
espaces extérieurs de la maison
ouais la terrasse assez cool on comprend
petit déj c'est mortel et ce serait bien
que les deux niveaux il a accès à une
sorte de terrasse comme ça vu tu dois
savoir plus propre et qu'on puisse aussi
à chacun d'accéder à son niveau
tu vois qu'il est plus vraiment c'est un
mélange qui est cool mais les deux
niveaux soit plus d'indépendants en fait
qu'ils sont plus indépendants et puis
qu'ils soient mieux c'est quoi ça
passerait par une terrasse qui n'existe
pas encore donc on va détruire l'escale
et voilà qui est là on va le déplacer un
peu à l'extérieur
du coup ça permettra aussi d'avoir un
accès privilégié à chaque check niveau
d'audience
et puis ça pour amener sera d'avoir une
terrasse prince soleil l'a donc
plusieurs ces coupes mais c'est de
mettre une petite douche extérieure en
tout comme ça d'ailleurs essayé en ville
rappelle avoir parlé là favelas
pacifiées
ce serait le nouvel eldorado pour les
bonnes affaires immobilières mais
attention acheter dans ces quartiers
n'est pas sans risque ici cette maison
là j'étais 50000 euros
on a partagé 50/50 et une maison comme
ça là prato sur le bund pourrait valoir
que même à zéro parce que cette maison
n'a pas de titre de propriété
puisqu'elle est pas reconnue parce que
du jour au lendemain on peut la détruire
et on peut partir et on a pris ce risque
avec raphaël on a fait ce pari ici quoi
on sait que
ça risque pas d'arriver quand même mais
comme il dit on n'a pas de titre de
propriété
comme tous les gens dans les favelas ça
viendra peut-être un jour mais bon après
la culture aussi des gens il ya quand
même un cinquième de la ville qui vit
dans des favelas
il ya l'état quand même investi dans les
réseaux ici il s'est introduit quand
même il a il a fait des améliorations
donc tous les gens qui sont ici ont
construit leur maison
wade étant tous plus ou moins un titre
de propriété après il ya une légende
urbaine qui dit que oui on aura
forcément une saveur 34
ici aucune loi ne les protègent et de
nombreuses constructions sont insalubres
ou édifié sur des zones à risque mais
pour axel vivre ici ce n'est pas qu'une
question d'argent
moi j'aime pas parler de bonnes affaires
ou bon coup parce que vraiment avec
raphaël on n'a pas du tout acheté cette
maison en pensant qu'on allait devenir
millionnaire grâce à ça c'est beaucoup
plus lié un coup de coeur avec cette
phase est là avec cette vue avec la
ville de rio et la culture carioca qui
nous a poussé à franchir le cap et
d'investir nos économies dans cette
maison construire des terrasses des
escaliers et des pièces supplémentaires
aucune autorisation à demander puisque
leurs maisons et illégale
l' aventure des gringos de la favela ne
fait que commencer
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là d'autres
favelas celle des quartiers nord elles
n'ont pas la vue sur mer et une très
mauvaise réputation
pour s'y rendre il faut prendre
l'avenida brasil une artère de 58 km de
long autour de laquelle s'enchevêtrent
d' immenses bidonvilles au milieu la
piscine de ramos un des lieux les plus
insolites de la ville un immense lagon
artificiel
[Musique]
le rendez vous de tous les favelas dos
10h du matin la figure incontournable du
quartier fait jean leroy de la piscine
si en famille
[Musique]
nous sommes sur la passerelle numéro 13
qui nous emmène à la piscine géante de
ramos aujourd'hui ça va être la fête
avec un soleil merveilleux comme ça ça
va être remplie de famille des mollahs
ces gens c'est un peu le grand frère et
à chaque fois c'est le même scénario
il vient tous les jours et il connaît
tout le monde ça c'est un copain
musicien tu fais un concert bientôt
ouais je joue le vendredi on se croise
là bas c'est l'un des hommes les plus
populaires des quartiers nord tu vas
bien on essaye de prendre un petit verre
ensemble ok bon sens alors lui c'est un
chef d'entreprise il fait un boulot d'un
lien on se voit tout à l'heure cette
piscine a été créé il y a dix ans entre
l'autoroute et la baie de guanabara
une ancienne plage à succès devenu
aujourd'hui impropre à la baignade
le gouvernement ici a investi une
fortune pour tenter de dépolluer la baie
de guanabara
ils veulent nettoyer les îles aussi okc
parce qu'ici c'était la plage de ramos
ici c'était un grand succès dans les
années 70-80 la plage de ramos était
sensationnelle il ya énormément de
travail ici beaucoup de choses à faire
pour sauver la bête
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus du tout ce
béni aujourd'hui c'est impossible de se
baigner c'est pas propre
il ya quoi là dedans il ya tout ici
c'est la baie de guanabara il ya toutes
sortes de pollutions
le laisser-aller des pouvoirs publics et
une mauvaise gestion des déchets ont
ravagé cette partie du littoral
privé de plage les habitants des
quartiers nord n'ont plus le choix
[Musique]
pour continuer de se baigner ils vont à
la piscine
l'eau de la piscine vient de la baie de
guanabara
elles rendent par là et la balle passe
par un système de filtrage avec du
chlore dans cette machine est ensuite à
les rejeter dans le boss pouvoir paquet
à la veille l'eau arrive par ces
canalisations et il ya une valve pour
éviter qu'il y ait trop de chlore dans
l'eau ficam louis tora au caire depuis
qu'ils ont créé la piscine de ramallah
je ne mets plus les pieds à copacabana
déjà parce que j'habite de l'autre côté
de la ville
et puis je préfère venir ici il fait
comme quoi craquer 100 tonnes je perçois
que quoi stake poker parce que les gens
que je rencontre ce sont des gens que je
connais depuis mon enfance
donc des personnes que je vois depuis
que je suis tout petit et qui font
partie de mon milieu
[Musique]
j'aime bien
tu sais les piscines à ossun endroit
très attachant c'est comme le parfum
français c'est super bon 11 heures du
matin
la bière commence à couler à flots c'est
aussi le début de journée pour rosa elle
sert ozanam a préféré
c'est une bosseuse ans elle ramasse des
canettes quel âge as-tu 82 ans elle a 82
ans cette femme 82 ans
et voilà elle part avec des énormes sacs
pour gagner quelques euros
et combien vous gagnez avec ses canettes
je gagne 70 centimes par kilo quand on
ne veulent pas mon sac 70 centimes le
kilo il faut avoir beaucoup de canettes
il faut beaucoup travailler
ça c'est mon peuple c'est les miens
la parité
d'autres acteurs incontournables les
maîtres nageurs
voilà les pompiers de la piscine
alors comment ça se passe les gars
aujourd'hui les mois qui précèdent l'été
sont plus tranquilles les événements les
points souvent ce sont les noyades de
personnes qui ont trop bu des gens qui
deviennent difficiles à se courir ils ne
sont plus dans leur état normal
la chose la plus folle que j'ai vu ici
c'est une maman qui a perdu son bébé de
1 an et 2 mars à bien dans le bébé
savait à peine marcher il ne parlait pas
non plus ils l'ont laissé tout seul
et ils l'ont perdu on a mis deux heures
pour le retrouver
je trouve c'est absurde un si petit bébé
c'est une énorme responsabilité
mais on trouve beaucoup de cas comme ça
ici elle a vomi
il y à beaucoup d'enfants perdus ici
allez salut au revoir ils ont une lourde
mission dans quelques heures ce sera le
grand auch regarde il ya de plus en plus
demain qui est en train d'arriver
l'une des plus grandes piscines au monde
plus de 50000 personnes viennent s'y
baigner
[Musique]
et le dimanche c'est aussi jour de fête
que
fait jean est avec les siens ici pas de
gringo
un spot hors des circuits touristiques
[Musique]
une ambiance caliente mais bon enfant
quand les favelas dos s'amuse bien loin
des clichés ultra violents qui colle à
la peau de ces quartiers
[Musique]
après avoir fait la tournée de la
piscine fait gens se transforment en
commandant de bord direction la paix de
guanabara au nord de rio plus d'une
centaine d'îles et quelques surprises
comme l'île de pâques et heures
ça va être une super balade vous allez
voir
fait j'en ai célèbre ici car c'est un
bon vivant mais aussi un agitateur
d'idées pour sa communauté
maintenant on va allumer notre barbecue
sa dernière idée des excursions en
bateau dans les îles de la baie il n'y a
pas de raison que ces plaisirs ne soit
réservé qu'aux riches ça c'est la
piscine qu'on voit au loin
ouais c'est la piscine de ramos que tu
vois là
la même promenade en bateau à partir des
quartiers sud de rio ça doit coûter
autour de 40 euros
ici on fait pour 20 euros et on inclut
même les bières c'est beaucoup moins
cher
une formule low cost pour aller
découvrir les trésors de rio
la plupart des passagers de fées gens
n'ont jamais pris la mer
il ya beaucoup de gens qui n'ont jamais
été sur un bateau ils ne sont même pas
au courant qu'on propose à tous ceux qui
vivent dans les quartiers périphériques
ne sont jamais venus dans la baie de
guanabara
ils ne connaissent pas cette promenade
elle par exemple là bas elle n'a jamais
été vu ma tu l'as déjà fait un bateau
non mais moi je me suis jamais venu elle
non plus n'a jamais fait cette fois m
tous les week-ends barbecue et grosse
détente au programme
[Musique]
oui
et
on oublie tous ces problèmes aujourd'hui
c'est les vacances avec mes jambes
[Musique]
le yachtman et son équipage vont
accoster à pâques et à une petite île en
face de rio une ancienne ville coloniale
portugaise où le temps semble s'être
arrêté
[Musique]
on vient d'arriver sur l'île de pâques
et à roanne on va profiter de cet
endroit il ya beaucoup de touristes ici
aujourd'hui
j'ai dit on monte en voiture simone
un gros bol d'air loin de la favela
j'ai déjà ramené pas mal de gens ici des
amis aussi cette promenade en bateau
directement de la piscine héros c'est
toujours très émouvant à pâques et à je
me sens bien
vraiment très bien une ambiance petits
baigneurs avec sa plage de sable fin et
ses pédalos kitsch allez-y faites un
tour
comment on fait pour partir juste un
petit tour allait pas trop loin 7 il
fait partie de la ville de rio une de
ses nombreuses perles accessible à moins
d'une heure de bateau j'adore cet
endroit
l'air est pur on peut faire du pédalo du
vélo en famille c'est rare bacchetta
c'est un petit paradis
tous les habitants de rio devrait
connaître cet endroit parce que le pack
est assez bon cela t'apporte paix et
armement
le décor vue du ciel s'est assombri la
baie de guanabara souffre d'une
pollution sans précédent et goût
directement déversées dans la mer
déchetterie à ciel ouvert sans compter
le boom de l'industrie pétrolière
[Musique]
et
le littoral de rio est en danger
le gouvernement brésilien s'est engagé à
tout nettoyer
une mission qui permettra peut-être que
la plus belles baies du monde garde ses
lettres de noblesse
[Musique]
oui
et
m
[Musique]
et